اذا مشاهدينا اهلا بكم انا ميسون عزام
واحييكم ونستمر في هذه التغطيه للاوضاع في
السودان هدوء حذر في السودان يسود قبل
ساعات من انتهاء هدنه الثلاث ايام او
الثلاثه ايام التي تخللتها مواجهات بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ياتي ذلك فيما
اكدت مصادر للعربيه اكدت ان الكثير من
سجناء سجن كوبر بالخرطوم اطلق سراحهم في
وقت تتفاقم فيه ازمه النزوح اضافه الى
ازمه صحيه بدات تتكشف مع خروجه مستشفيات
عن الخدمه هذا وبدات فرنسا وايضا بريطانيا
ودول اخرى بداوا باجلاء رعاياهم من
السودان بعد تاكيد الولايات المتحده اخلاء
سفرتها في الخرطوم في وقت يتخوف المجتمع
الدولي من ان يتحول وتتحول المواجهات الى
مرحله اللاعوده بين طرفي الصراع
مشكله المويه الحقيقه مشكله كبيره الناس
اللي بيعاني منها معان
يعني حتى الموت الصحه في المحلات الدياريه
الان الرجاء استخدموا لعبات الجوفيه
والمعانة كبير جدا
وهي مياه برضو مش صالحه للشرب غير ما هي
ممكن يتم استخدام
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا كما ذكرنا في المقدمه
الانظار تتجه الى سجن كوبر هذه صور يتم
تداولها لما يقال بانه هروب وخروج لعدد من
السجناء هذا السجن الذي [__] رموز النظام
بالرغم من انه الجيش السوداني كان قد اكد
ان الجميع قيد الاحتجاز الا ان هذه الصور
يتم تداولها ويتم الحديث عن انها من سجن
كوبر وانه هناك عمليه هروب لعدد كبير من
السجناء من رموز النظام السابق بالامس كنا
نتحدث عن سجن الهدى الذي واجه احداث كثيره
الجيش اتهم في حينها قوات الدعم السريع
بالاغاره على ذلك السجن لما قال بانها
عمليه لتحرير السجناء عنوه تحت تهديد
السلاح قوات الدعم السريع في حينها تبرات
من ذلك ونفت الاتهامات الا ان البعض كان
قد اشار بالامس ان ذلك
مفاده ان احداث سجن الهدى ما هي الا مقدمه
لتهيئه المسرح الاقتحام سجن كوبر بالخرطوم
بحري بهدف اطلاق سراح قاده التنظيمات
الاسلامويه على راسهم طبعا الرئيس المخلوع
عمر البشير ونائبه علي عثمان وبكري حسن
صالح طبعا وفيكم باي جديد حول هذه النقطه
حاله ورودها ولكن دعونا نتعرف من مراسل
العربيه من الخرطوم سالم الهاشمي حول
المعلومات المتوفر لديهم ما الذي يحدث على
الارض عن ماذا نتحدث هنا في سجن كوبر
نعم بحسب
على حسب بعض الروايات انه فتحت الابواب
للمساجيل لانه لا توجد مياه شرب في داخل
في داخل السجن السجن كوبر وانه تم اطلاق
صراح كل الموجودين في السجن على السياسيين
الذين ما زالوا يتحقرون عليهم
بما فيهم رئيس النظام السابق
وايضا البقيه من السياسيين الذين
يتبعون لحزب المؤتمر الوطني انهم متحصب
عليهم في داخل
السجن ما غير غيره تم اطلاق سراحته او سمح
لهم بالخروج هذا بحسب افادات من مصادر في
الشرطه وهل لدينا معلومات عن الوضع الصحي
والانسان بصوره عامه لسياسيين الذين ذكرت
بانه المعلومات تقول بانهم لا زالوا في
السجون خاصه في ظل ما ذكرته من عدم توفر
المياه وغيره
ا
اي تفاصيل
اخرى لكن هذه هي المعلومه فقط التي وردت
الينا بانه خرج كل السجناء عدا
في داخل من يسيطر على سجن الان سالم البعض
كان يتحدث عن انه كل القيادات والجنود غير
متواجدين او خرجوا وتركوا السجن هل هذا
صحيح اي معلومات
التي ذكرتها لك قبل قليل انه موجودين
ومتحصل عليهم هذه المعلومات
عن الشرطه عن من يسيطر على هذا السجن الان
نعم هذا السجن من حوله اذا كانت او بالقرب
منهم ليس من حوله لكن بالقرب منه كانت
هناك اشتباكات اصلا بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السجن في كوبر وكذلك
الاشتباقات كانت في ذلك الحي بالتحديد
فترات السابقه
بعد ذلك
جاءت
المسلحه قبل ذلك نفذ ان يكون هناك اشتباك
في محيط سجن كوبر وصدر ذلك في احدى
بياناتها ثم تحدثت الينا كذلك بانه لا
يوجد اي اشتباك في محفظه كان هذا في بدايه
ايام هذه الاشتباسات الى جاء اليوم وخرج
هؤلاء المساجين ثم تواصلنا معه
مصادر في داخل الشرطه تاكدوا لنا ان
المساجين خرجوا لكن السياسيين من رموز
النظام السابق مازال متحفظ عليه في داخل
السجن فقط ولم يدلو باي معلومات اخرى طبعا
كانت المصادر تتحدث عن انه بالفعل داخل
السجن الوضع بالغ السوء وتدهور عقب انسحاب
ما قالوا بانه انسحاب للحراسات انعدام
الماء والاكل والعلاج طوال هذه الايام كان
صحيفه السوداني بالامس تتحدث عن ان خمس
نزلاء خمسه نزلاء بسجن كوبر قتلوا اثراء
اصابتهم بمقذوفات داخل محبسهم لا اعلم ان
كان لديك معلومات سالم ولكن على كل نعود
اليك في سياق هذه النشره وغيرها حاله ورود
الجديد ينضم الي الان عبر الهاتف وزير
خارجيه جنوب السودان ديني قداو اهلا بك
سيدي
معالي الوزير هل لك ان تعطينا قراءتكم في
جنوب السودان لما يحدث في السودان وكنتم
بالاضافه الى مصر عرضتم الوساطه هل حصلتم
على رد
اولا شكرا جزيلا
على استضافه بصفتي وزير
للخارجيه لجنوب السودان الجنوب السودان
ينظر الى هذه الاوضاع التي تعيشها السودان
بقلق
لان اي شيء قد يحدث في السودان سوف تكون
له تداعيات على المنطقه باوسعها
وقد يذكرنا بالاحداث التي عاشها السودان
في السابق
وكل من يساعده على وقف اطلاق النار من
خلال الوساطه او من خلال تامين ممرات
انسانيه للسودان سوف او تقديم المياه او
اي مؤن للمواطنين في الخرطوم سوف يكون
موضع تقدير
سيد دنق عندما تتحدث عن
المساعدات لديكم في السودان جنوب السودان
800 الف سوداني هل انتم على استعداد
لاستقبال المزيد هل من استعدادات قائمه
سلفا باستقبال لمجموعه من السودانيين
لسنوات عده وامنا ماوى لهم
واننا سعداء لتامين ماوى وملجا لهم هنا
وحتى اللحظه يوجد لدينا
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف لاجئ من سودان على مر
السنوات الخمسه الماضيه وهؤلاء اللاجئون
يعيشون
بكرامه في جنوب السودان
واننا مستعدون لاستقبال المزيد من
اللاجئين من السودان على استعداد
الاستقبال السودانيين اللاجئين ولكن ايضا
كان هناك في طرح تم الاعلان عنه من مصر
بالشراكه معكم
بعرض وساطه في السودان بين الطرفين هل
وصلكم اي رد هل لا زالت المساعي قائمه حتى
الان الدور الذي تقومون به
شكرا جزيلا ان رئيسنا كان قد اجرى محادثه
هاتفيه مع
اخيه الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
وقد تطرق في
محادثتهما الى الوضع الحالي وكيف يمكن
لهما العمل
على حث
الجنرال برهان وحميتي على وقف
قبول اطلاق النار والعوده لطاوله
المفاوضات
بحيث يتم
وقدي الخلافات بين الطرفين المتحاربين دون
احداث المزيد من ازهق حياه البشر
وبالمقادير
هل انتشر مع
الطرق او لا كجنوب السودان
نعم ان رئيس البلاد كان على اتصال مع كل
من الجنرلين
وخلال الايام القليله الماضيه على وجه
التحديث كان قد اهاب بالجنرال البرهان
والجنر الحميطي
للعمل
على وقف العمل العدائيه
مقر لاتفاق جوبا للسلام هل تتوقعون انه
يمكن ان يكون لكم دور بهذا الاطار فيما
يتعلق بالحل للازمه الان من خلال محادثه
رئيس جنوب السودان سلفاكير مع الجانبين هل
تلمستم نوع من القبول لكونكم وسيط محايد
او لا
مقاربتنا في جنوب السودان
تنظر الى ان هذه المشكله هي مشكله سودانيه
وان السودان يجب ان ينبع من السودانيين
انفسهم في المقام الاول
وحالنا حال دول الاخرى المجاوره للسودان
فان واجبنا فقط تقديمي العون والمساعده
ولكن الحل سوف ينبع من السودان لانها ليست
ليست مساله الجنرال برهان او حميتي بل
هناك احزاب سياسيه اخرى التي يجلب عليها
ان تشارك في
صوغي الحل السياسي الذي سوف يزدل الستاره
على الحرب الحاليه الدائره في البلاد وسوف
يعمل على تامين السلام نعم جنوب السودان
سوف يبقى ملتزما
بصفته بلد مجاور للسودان في ايجاد الحل
الملائم للمشكله السودانيه لكن لكن حل
المشكله بصوره الاساسيه سوف تاتي من الشعب
السوداني ذاته
سوداني بحث ولكن بالمقابل هذا لا يمنع
ذكرت بالبدايه
انه مت
داعيات ليس فقط علاقه الجوار ولكن خطوط
الانابيب فيما بينكم العلاقات الاقتصاديه
وغيرها يعني ذلك ان
السودان جنوب السودان
سيتاثر مباشره اليس كذلك
نعم هذا صحيح فاننا لا ننكر ان جنوب
السودان قد يتاثر من جراء الاوضاع الذي
تعيشه السودان
ولاسيما في ما يخص
خطوطي انابيب النفط التي تمتد بين البلدين
عبر بورسودان هذه مشكله كبيره قد تحمل
تداعيات كبيره لكن عندما نقول انها مشكله
سودانيه فهذا يعني بان كافه الاطراف داخل
السوداني يجب ان تساهم في حل المشكله
وانه يجب حلها في من قبل السودانيين لكننا
نستطيع كدوله المجاوره ان نساعد في اعطاء
في اعطاء
المشوره والتوجيه وان نكون
كمقر لتحقيق السلام بين الشعب السوداني
هل تعتقد انه السودان
ربما قابل لمزيد من التقسيم فيه او لا في
ظل التركيبه الداخليه بالسودان
[موسيقى]
نعمل
لا تصل الامور الى المزيد من المشاكل
وان القاده الحنيين في السودان سوف يعملان
على
تذليل الخلافات فيما بينهما
والتفادي اي شبح للتقسيم هل
تتابعون بقلق سحب الدول لاعتاتها
الدبلوماسيه
او انه هذا امر طبيعي بالنسبه لكم ويجب ان
يكون
هذه ليست بمساله طبيعيه فيما يخص الاوضاع
المساله تتعلق بسلامه الرعايه
الاجانب وعدد كبير منهم قدم انتقل عبر
حدود جنوب السودان وهناك مواطنون اخرى
هناك مواطنون اخرون لقد انتقلوا ايضا عبر
بورسودان هذه ليست بمساله طبيعيه
ان يتم سحب كل هؤلاء الناس وان معظمهم قد
تركوا منازلهم واملاكهم فضلا عن موت البعض
الاخر
كان معنا على الهاتف وزير خارجيه جنوب
السودان دنيق داو شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
هذا واعلن المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه
في السودان خالد عمر يوسف ان النزاع
الحالي في السودان سيكون سببا في ضياع
البلاد دون استعادتها مؤكدا انها حرب لا
ينتصر فيها اي طرف يوسف اشار الى ما
اعتبرها فرصه متاحه حاليا لايقاف الحرب
وتشكيل جبهه مدنيه لتجاوز الازمه الراهنه
كما اكد على اهميه واولويه اجتماع الاطراف
العسكريه والمدنيه على طاوله الحوار
للتواصل الى حل دائم
هذا هو رغم الهدوء الحذر ميدانيا بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع تتواصل
الاشتباكات بشكل متقطع في العاصمه الخرطوم
في مشاهدت بعض احياء بحري واندرمان
والخرطوم تحليقا لطيران الحربي بحسب شهود
عيان من جهه اخرى اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع
طيران الجيش بقصف مواقعها في منطقه كفوري
بالخرطوم بحري هذا ويتواصل الانقطاع في
خدمه المياه في مدينه بحري وعدد من احياء
ولايه الخرطوم ومن المقرر ان تنتهي مساء
هذا اليوم هدنه كان وافق عليها الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع بينما تواصلت حركه
النزوح من الخرطوم الى الولايات السودانيه
الاخرى
الشعب السوداني اكثر من اكتوى بنار هذه
الحرب القصه التاليه تحكي فقدان عائله
لابنها نتيجه سقوط مقذوف عليه في المنزل
دعونا نتابع
في السودان الصراع متوسط بين المكونين
العسكريين
ايام المره يعيشها السودانيون الذين
تطلعوا لعهد جديد تميزه الديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
حياه العشرات تحولت لماساه حقيقيه بسبب
تدهور الوضع الامني صراع تلو اخر عمق
الازمه وزاد من حده التممل والاستياء
ملامح الحزن والاسى خيمت على وجه ادريس
حسن الذي فقد ابن اخيه عندما اخترقت قذيفه
النافذه المنزل ادت لمقتله على سريره
[موسيقى]
للبردان على العجال الليله فقدناه
والمرحوم ده ما في سريره
بس يعني
القصف تسبب بحروق لوالده الضحيه التي صدمت
من هول الحادثه
[موسيقى]
السرير
الحياه المدنيه توقفت في السودان
مناطق سكنيه مكتظه بالسكان ومتخامه
بالرصاص
[موسيقى]
وعلى صعيد عمليات الاجلاء المستمره في
السودان قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني قال
ان القوات المسلحه اتمت عمليه اجلاء معقده
وسريعه للدبلوماسيين البريطانيين
ولعائلاتهم من السودان مضيفا ان بريطانيا
تسعى بكل الوسائل لوقف اراقه الدماء في
السودان وضمان سلامه البريطانيين المتبقين
هناك مؤكدا انها تحث الاطراف كافه على
القاء الاسلحه وايقاف اطلاق النار
من جانبه قال وزير الدفاع البريطاني ان
عمليه الاجلاء جاءت بسبب التهديدات
المتصاعده جراء المواجهات في السودان
مشيرا الى مشاركه 1200 جندي بريطاني في
العمليه من ضمنهم سته عشر لواء هجوم جوي
ومشات البحريه الملكيه وسلاح الجو الملكي
البريطاني
وقد اكد نائب رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
اوليفر ان الوضع في السودان معقد ويتصاعد
بوتيره سريعه نتابع
من الواضح ان الوضع في السودان سريع
الوتيره ومعقد
اولوياتنا هي دعم الرعايه البريطانيين
ويعمل وزير الدفاع الان لدعم وزاره
الخارجيه لكن لن اعلق لاسباب الامنيه على
الوضع الحالي من حيث التحركات على الارض
المزيد معنا من لندن مصطفى زارو مراسل
العربيه اهلا بك مصطفى مزيد من التفاصيل
حول عمليه الاجلاء هذه يبدو انها كبرى
ولكن هناك من بقي في السودان هل لدينا
ارقام
حقيقه ميسون لم تكشف الحكومه عن عدد
الموظفين الذين تم اجلائهم اليوم
لكن هناك تقرير تفيد بان ربما في حوالي
25 موظفا في السفاره نقل الان الى
دول مجاوره لمواصله عملهم بسبب الاعمال
العنف المتواصله هناك بالنسبه للمواطنين
البريطانيين الرساله الوحيده التي سمعناها
من وزير الخارجيه وهو يعني مطالبه
البريطانيين العالقيين في السودان باخطار
وزاره الخارجيه بمكان وجودهم ونصحتهم
بالبقاء في منازل المحطه اذا ما توفرت
هناك فرصه سيتم اجلائهم ربما هناك يعني
بضعه مئات من
البريطانيين يتواجدون حاليا في السودان
ولكن ليست هناك اي ارقام دقيقه يعني في
اليوم تقريبا في اليوم الثالث من اعمق في
السودان كشف وزير وزير المكلف بشؤون
افريقيا بان السفاره تلقت حينها 100 اتصال
من مواطنين بريطاني وبالتالي ربما هذا
العدد ربما العدد الاتصالات زاد خلال هذه
الفتره الماضيه وبالتالي لا نعرف ارقام
حقيقيه ممن تم اجلؤهم او اولئك الذين لا
يزالون في السودان حاليا
ان بريطانيا تسعى بكل الوسائل لوقف اراقه
الدماء في السودان طبيعه الدور الذي تلعبه
بريطانيا في هذه الازمه
دور بريطانيا كدور حلفاء يعني بالمنطقه
وايضا الحلفاء الغربيين يتم يعني التواصل
مع مختلف
الدول وخاصه ان وزير الخارجيه اجراء
اتصالات عديده مع نظرائه في فرنسا
والسعوديه والامارات بالاضافه الى جيبوتي
وايضا الولايات المتحده ويجب التذكير بان
يعني اجلاء المواطنين البريطانيين من
السفاره البريطانيه كان ايضا بالتنسيق مع
الحلفاء يعني الولايات المتحده وايضا
وايضا فرنسا بالاضافه الى السعوديه ايضا
بالطبع هذا يعني هذا المملكه المتحده تعمل
في اطار يعني
اتصالات يعني بين دوليه بين بين حلفائها
وايضا هناك مسار اخر ربما سنسمع عن
تفاصيله ربما بدايه الاسبوع المقبل لان
بريطانيا تريد ان ان تعقد جلسه خاصه فيما
يتعلق في السودان والرساله الواضحه وهو
يجب على الاطراف
متصارعه في السودان ان يعودوا الى
المفاوضات بالتالي الامر جد معقد
ورئيس الوزراء رئيس
اجتماع لخليه الازمه امس ولربما كانت يعني
مثمره وربما بان تم اجلاء على الاقل
الموظفين الدبلوماسيين البريطانيين حاليا
تنظر وزاره الخارجيه ببقيه البريطانيين في
السودان اشارت بريطانيا والدفاع تحديدا
الى تهديدات متصاعده تتعلق بالوضع العام
هنا نتحدث
مصطفى او انه هناك شيء محدد فيما يتعلق
بالتواجد البريطاني
اذا يعني اذا بالعوده الى بضعه ايام
الماضيه يعني شاهدنا وسمعنا بان تم
استهداف دبلوماسيين ولا سيما السياره تسير
الامريكي بالاضافه ربما الى دبلوماسيين
اخرين وبالتالي انه يعني وضع او مكان
السفاره البريطانيه هي بين
يعني في منتصف الص الدائره بين القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم العسكري
وبالتالي كانت هناك ربما يعني معلومات
استخباراتيه بانه سيتم استهداف
الدبلوماسيين ولجات الى اجراء بسرعه وخاصه
وان قد
اذا ما تم القبض على قد يتم يعني استخدام
في وقت لاحق وبالتالي الحكومه البريطانيه
قررت اجلاء
يعني بالتنسيق مع حلفائها من لندن مصطفى
زارو مراسل العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المعلومات
هذا وكانت الخارجيه المصريه اكدت انها
بدات اجراءات الرعايه المصريين بالتنسيق
اجلائهم طبعا بالتنسيق مع السلطات
السودانيه الخارجيه المصريه كانت قد اعلنت
في وقت سابق اصابه احد اعضاء السفاره في
الخرطوم بطلق ناري واكدت ان هذا الحادث
يؤكد مره اخرى على ضروره توخي اقصى درجات
الحذر حفاظا على سلامه المواطنين
والدبلوماسيين الخارجيه المصريه دعت
المواطنين المصريين الموجودين خارج
الخرطوم الى التوجه الى مدينتي حلفا
وبورتسودان تمهيدا لاجلائهم
بالمزيد معنا من القاهره اللواء معتصم
العجب المحلل العسكري وعضو تجمع قدامه
المحاربين السودانيين اهلا بك اللواء تعني
ابدا بمتابعتك لعمليات الاجلاء
ما واجهته من صعاب تفضل
حقيقه في في وضع
قوات متشابكه في منطقه ضيقه جدا ما في اي
حدود بيناتها ما في اي
فواصل بيناته سواء كانت طبيعيه او صناعيه
ووجود المواقع بتاعت السفارات
يعني موجوده محصوره في حي العمارات حي
العمارات ده اللي هو قريب للمطار معظمه
يعني معظمه السفارات عدد السفاره
الامريكيه وفي السفاره الصينيه موجوده في
حته يعني برضو في نفس الايريا لكن بعيده
شويه حتى المنشيه
المهم انه
الاشتباكات العنيفه كلها دارت في المنطقه
دي
في خطر من عليهم في عمليات الاجلاء او في
وجود
الحاجه الثانيه
التحرك ده بالدموع والشراط يعني بده
مؤشرات انه في جماعات مضطرفه موجوده في في
نص في القوات نفسها قوات متطرفه لابسه
ملابس طبعا اسهل حاجه يتعمل مصنع
للبسه العسكري فممكن الواحد يكون عنده لبس
الشرطه وعنده لبس دعم السريع وعنده لبس
القوات المسلحه وهي اطراف ولا منتسبه لاي
وحده من الثلاثه دي الخطوره هنا يعني
رغم هذا الدفاع
نعمات كثيره ولكن يبدو ان الخارجيه
المصريه تتحدث عن محاوله
حل والقفز على هذه الصعوبات مصادر العربيه
تتحدث عن انه بالفعل اعطت الضوء الاخضر
الان لبدء عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
وايضا تحدثت عن ان الجيشين المصري
والسوداني ينسقان لبدء هذه العمليه وقد
قامت مصر بتزويد تفاصيل الممرات الامنه
لنقل المصريين لاماكن الاجلاء كما انه
الجيش السوداني سيتولى مرافقه قوافل
المصريين حتى المعابر الحدوديه وحول
المعابر الحدوديه ايضا هناك انباء تتحدث
عن ان مصر نشرت قوات امنيه على معابرها
الحدوديه مع السودان لتامين عمليات
الاجلاء مرافقه
المصريين الذين يتم اجلائهم من قبل الجيش
السوداني ماذا تعني
المشكله في المرافقه طبعا المسافه طبعا من
من من
الخرطوم لحد الحدود المصريه يعني تقريبا
حدود في حوالي الف الف كيلو متر
1100 حاجه بالشكل ده كويس
التحرك من الخرطوم المشكله في الخرطوم
يعني مجرد ما انت طلعت من حدود الخرطوم او
لو ماشي في طريق شريان الشمال مثلا حتمشي
تمر
نهايتهم درمان منطقه ام درمان انت طلعت
منه بعد ما في مشكله يعني كان في مشكله في
المنطقه بتاعت مروي ومروه بعيده من الطريق
ده يعني ما في اي مشكله بعد ما تطلع من
الخرطوم المشكله في الخرطوم نشر قوات مع
الحراسات دي حتكون انك تطلع من حدود
الخرطوم طيب وبعدها نشر القوه
السودان معتصم عذرا اذا كانت المشكله
الاساسيه هي فقط فكره الخروج من الخرطوم
لماذا نشر القوات الامنيه على المعابر
الحدوديه مع السودان
برايك
طبعا برايي انه الخوف من تسلل من تسلل
عناصر
الخوف من هنا يعني نشر الحدود ما لا تامين
المواكب دي طبعا
والنشر القوات على على الحدود خوف من
تسلل
جماعات ارهابيه موجوده باسلحتها بكام ممكن
تجي داخله يعني
كذا تنظيم موجود نشط نشط ممكن يخش مصر لاي
غرض يعني ولازم يؤمنوا نفسه يعني
من القاهره اللواء معتصم العجب المحلل
العسكري عضو تجمع قدامه المحاربين
السودانيين شكرا جزيلا لك
وعلى صعيد الجهود الدوليه والاقليميه لوقف
التصعيد في السودان بحث وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان مع مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل بحث الجهود المبذوله لوقف
التصعيد العسكري بين الاطراف المتنازعه
وانهاء العنف في السودان اضافه الى توفير
الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين السودانيين
والمقيمين مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي كشف عن توافق سعودي
اوروبي على العمل الجماعي من اجل وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان
هذا هو مع استمرار المواجهات تتفاقم
الازمه الصحيه في السودان اعلن مدير منظمه
الصحه العالميه ان المؤسسات الصحيه في
السودان تعرضت لهجمات داعيا الى توقف ذلك
على الفور واكد تدرس ادهانهم انه لا ينبغي
استهداف مقدمين رعايه الصحيه او المرافق
الصحيه لضمان تقديم الخدمات للمرضى
ومن جانبها وفي احدث الخروقات بشان
الاوضاع الصحيه المترديه اعلنت وزاره
الصحه السودانيه عن تعذر استقبال المرضى
في مركز الغسل الكلوي في مستشفى
النوى التعليمي حيث توقف تقديم الخدمات
فيه الصحه قالت ان المشفى يعاني من نقص
الكوارث العامله في وقت تتكدس فيه المرضى
بحثا عن تلقي العلاج الوزاره دعت الكوادر
الطبيه القريبه من المركز للانضمام لتقديم
المساعده الطبيه العاجله وقد ناشدت
المتطوعين واهالي المرضى بتوفير المسكن
والحوافز لاستقبال المرضى
قبل ذلك اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان ارتفاع
عدد ضحايا الاشتباكات الى 264 قتيلا من
المدنيين
و1543 جريحا اللجنه هو في بيان لها اوضحت
ان هناك الكثير من الاصابات والوفيات غير
مشموله في هذا الحصر حيث لم تتمكن من
الوصول الى المستشفيات لصعوبه التنقل
والوضع الامني في البلاد
لكن مع تضارب الارقام بشان اعداد الضحايا
منذ اندلاع المواجهات في الخامسه عشر من
ابريل اليكم لمحه عامه على خارطه الوضع
الميداني بحسب مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه
للامم المتحده فان الاشتباكات العنيفه
تمركزت في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
وكذلك في بحر اما في الفاشر بولايه شمال
دارفور فقد شهدت اشتباكات متقطعه بين طرفي
الصراع باستخدام الاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه
هذا وحضرت لجنو الاحياء في واد مدني
بولايه الجزيره من اشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريعه على طول الطريق من
الخرطوم الى مدني الذي كان احد الطرق
الرئيسيه التي يستخدمها الفارون من
العاصمه ونتيجه الاشتباكات المستمره ولنقص
السلع الاساسيه نزح بين 10 الى 20,000 شخص
هم من النساء والاطفال الى تشاد المجاوره
وفقا لمفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين ورصد مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه بال
المتحده مقتل
413 شخصا واصابه 3500 اخرين في الاشتباكات
حتى الحادي والعشرين من ابريل الجاري ذكر
تقرير للمكتب ان الخرطوم سجلت اعلى عدد من
القتلى بمئه واثنتين
ولايه في شمال كردفان نتحدث عن 95 قتيل
وشمال دارفور وحده 60 قتيل مع استمرار
الاقتتال لا يزال عدد القتلى مرشح للزياده
الناس
المشكله بتاعت المويه ثمانيه ايام بالليله
في بدايه الاحداث لم يعني لا توجد اننا
ماء تماما ولا يوجد عندنا كهرباء فكنا في
ظلام
هذا هو نشرت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه صورا
لما قالت انها عمليه اجراء مدنيين من
الخرطوم باتجاه بورد سودان لم تحدد
الوكاله اذا كانت العمليه تخص نقله
دبلوماسيين اجانب ام رعايه دول اجنبيه
مقيمين بالخرطوم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا صور من بورت سودان كما تبعنا ومن هناك
معنى الصحفي عبد القادر بكاش اللي طلعنا
على الاوضاع في بورت سودان وعمليات
الاجلاء هناك تفضل
مرحبا الحمد لله عمليات الاجلاء تمديد
بصوره
وزاره الدفاع يعني تبع السياسه بالتنسيق
مع عدد من الدول
لا بعد الرعايه وبعد البيسات الدبلوماتيه
الان تجري عمليات لادخال طاريات سعوديه
وهنديه وغيرها لاجلاء رعايههم وكذلك هناك
جهودان
باشراف وزاره الدفاع يتم عمليه اجلاء لبعض
الاردنيين الان حاليا تم بعمليه الاجراء
الاجراءات المطار هل لدينا ارقام عن عدد
من تم اجلائهم حتى الان ومن اي دول هم
هناك اعداد يعني العدد ليست لدي ارقام
دقيقه حتى الان لكن هناك اجلال يستمر منذ
الامس الان والان النساء ايضا ستقوم باخره
مدنيه من ميناء الشواكل الخاص بحركه
الركاب الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه ايضا
ستاخذ عدد كبير من الرعايه العرب لجلائهم
الى دولهم
عدد من الدول تقوم باجلاء عدد من رعاياها
وايضا رعايا دول اخرى وهنا تاتي عمليه
التنسيق ما بين الدول الى اي حد هي قائمه
وبالمقابل كيف تسير بثلاثه تشاهد هل هناك
من اشخاص ممن تقطعت بهم السبل ام ماذا
هناك اعداد كبيره من الرعايه الدول
والدبلوماسيين بعضهم وصل مدينه
ان شاء الله
وهناك تنسيق بين عدد كبير من الدول لاجلاء
عبر المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهناك ايضا جهود تجري في المطار
تنظيم رحلات مباشره الى بعض الدول عبر
مطار بورسودان باشراف وزاره الدفاع حركه
المياه الجويه الان مغلقه حتى الان في
الطائرات الطيران المدني لكن الان بدات
العسكريه او اشراف وزاره الدفاع يتم عبر
مطار بورسودان اجراء بعض الرعايه وهل يمكن
القول انه بهذه الفتره الاجواء صافيه
والسماء صافيه
وربما يمكن ان نقول انه
الهدوء هو السيد الموقف في هذه المرحله
السودان بصوره عامه منذ اليوم الثاني
للاحداث امن تماما والتنميه جميع وحدات
الدعم العسكري تم تصممها من قبل القوات
المسلحه والان الاجواء عامله تماما وبرا
وبهرا الان شرق السودان عامل تماما وهركت
الملاحه ملتزمه الملاحه البحريه ملتزمه في
المهله السودانيه بصوره ممتازه ولم تشهد
اي توقف منذ الايام الاولى الحمد لله الان
كل البواخر المدنيه بداء التجاريه ترد
وتجد لميناء بورسودان بكل ثلاثه لم تشهد
اي ربطه او توقف وكذلك الارياف
كل مناطق ولايه البحر الاحمر ومناطق ولايه
كسلا حتى الان الحمد لله امنه تماما كيف
تتم عمليه تنظيم الاجلاء
وبالمقابل اين يتجمع هؤلاء الناس وكيف هي
الاستعدادات لاستقبالهم قبل ان تتم
العمليه
يتم التفويج عبر وزاره الدفاع بتنسيق مع
الاجهزه العسكريه
وحتى الان الحمد لله الوقود تسال بسلاسه
لم تشهد اي توتر على الطريق وكذلك مدينه
بورسودان الان في اي تماما من الجانب
الرسمي والجانب الشعبي هناك عدد من
المنظمات المجتمع المدني والخيلين لتبني
بعد الاسر التي يعني من السودانيين الذين
نزلوا الى ولايه البحر الاحمر ايضا
باعتبارها من المناطق الامنه هناك جهود
لواءهم وللتنظيم والتسهيل حركه حركتهم الى
ولايه البحر الاحمر والمشاركه في استدامه
الخدمات داخل المدينه بعيشه تتوفر يعني
بصوره منتظمه الكهرباء والمياه والخدمات
الصينيه حتى الان مدينه برشلونه الان لم
تشهد اي اشكالات في جانب القدم الخوف
دائما ما يقال من الخرطوم من داخل الخرطوم
كيف يتم نقلهم وتجميعهم من هناك
هناك ترتيبات امنيه تتم في ولايه الخرطوم
بواسطه القوات المسلحه بالتنسيق مع
الاجهزه العسكريه الاخرى
ويتم الاجلاء بطرق معينه بشكل التعميم
معين بشكل تفويج معين بالتنسيق مع
السفارات لاجلال الاجانب وكذلك الانسان
المنظمات الامميه الان عدد كبير منها وصل
البورسودان ان شاء الله في تاريخهم
لدولهم باذن الله تعالى عمليه حتى التفويج
يعني عمليه الاجلاء من الخرطوم تتم وفقا
للترتيبات امنيه محكمه بالتنسيق مع كل
الوحدات العسكريه تشرف عليها وزاره الدفاع
والقوات المسلحه السودانيه يتم تعميم
الطرق وابري وانظمه اتصالات متقدمه وتعميم
الحمد لله كل البيئسات لم تشهد اي ركن في
الطريق اذا عمليه الاجلاء تتم من خلال
البر ولا يمكن من خلال الاجواء باي طريقه
او باخرى
[موسيقى]
لكن المقال مغلق تماما وكل الاجواء مغلقه
في ولايه الخرطوم وليست هناك اي اتجاه
لفتح الاجواء داخل الولايات الخرطوم في
الخليه طيب هل تمت عمليه اجلاء اي من
المصابين ان كان لديك معلومات
بالنسبه لولايات البحر الاعمال
بالنسبه لبورت سودان عمليات الاجلاء التي
تتم الان هل من مصابين لفتاه انظارك هل
هناك ام انه الكل
ليست هناك
معلوماتنا يعني مصممه
على يعني على سيارات معينه لولايه البحر
الاحمر ليست لديها امكانات كبيره لاستضافه
جرحه او مصابين باعادات كبيره مولات اخرى
لكن سنبحث في الساعات القادمه باذن الله
ان
جهود تمت في هذا الجانب من فوت سودان
الصحفي عبد القادر بكاش شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المعلومات
في الكويت عاد اليوم 25 مواطنا قادمين من
مطار جده الدولي في السعوديه وذلك طبعا في
اطار الخطه الطارئه التي نفتدتها وزاره
الخارجيه الكويتيه لاجلاء المواطنين
العالقين جراء الاشتباكات في السودان
نتابع
[موسيقى]
هذا هو مع استمرار خرق الهدنه تبادل
الطرفان لاتهامات بشان الاعتداء على
البعتات الدبلوماسيه بينما تستمر عمليه
الاجلاء للرعايه الاجانب حيث اتهم الجيش
السوداني قوات الدعم السريع بارتكاب
انتهاكات ضد بعتاد دبلوماسيه ليله امس
الجيش السوداني ذكر في بيان له ان عناصر
من الدعم السريع اعتدت على السفير
الماليزي والبعث القطري المتجهه الى
بورتسودان كما تعرض موكب السفاره الفرنسيه
لاطلاق نار مما ادى الى عودتهم وتعطيل
عمليه الاجلاء في المقابل قالت قوات الدعم
السريع في بيان ان طائرات الجيش هي التي
استهدفت موكب السفاره الفرنسيه شددت الدعم
السريع على التزامها بالهدنه وتسهيل حركه
الرعايه رعايه رعايه الاجانب لمناطق
الاجلاء
من جانبه اكد قائد قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان محمد حمدان دقلو لمنسق السياسي
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
التزام قواته المطلق بالهدنه الانسانيه
المعلنه مضيفا ان قواته مستعده لتقديم ما
يلزم من تسهيلات تساعد المواطنين
والجاليات الاجنبيه على المرور الى اماكن
امنه
قبل ذلك اتهم المستشار الاول لقائد قوات
الدعم السريع فارس النور في مقابله مع
العربيه اتهم عناصر قلائل انها مندسسه
بتنفيذ الاعتداءات على البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
هنالك الان
كتيبه كامله متفرغه من الطرف الاخر ترتدي
زي الدعم السريع لكي تدق السينما بين
الدعم السريع والمجتمع الدولي هم انضربوا
الرصاص على
السفاره الامريكيه هم اعتدوا على
سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي
النور نفل العربيه رغبه الدعم السريع في
ان تكون بديلا عن الجيش قال ان قوات الدعم
السريع مستعده للاندماج في الجيش بعد
تطهيره من عصابات سيطرت عليه وفق تعبيره
ان الجيش السوداني الان مختطف وابناء
الجيش الشعب السوداني وهنا في نقطه مهمه
انا اقوله يا اخي الكريم نحن حتى
يعني احنا ما طارحين نفسنا بديل للجيش
السوداني
نحن دايرين نطهر الجيش السوداني من
العصابه التي سيطرت عليه وبعد ذلك الجيش
السوداني هو الاساس لكي نكون جيش قومي نحن
سوف نندمج في الجيش السوداني لكي نكون جيش
رومي يحمي الدستور
يحمل البلاد من الاعداء الخارجيين
هذا هدفنا نحن لسنا بديل للجيش
والمزيد معنا من الخرطوم بحري الصحفي عمار
ابو شيبه اهلا بك عمار بدايه هل لا زال
الهدوء سيد الموقف وهل لدينا اي معلومات
عما يحدث في سجن كوبر
[موسيقى]
ورده ومعلومات
خفيفه في عدد من
ابطال
وفي مدينه بحري يعني صباحا اليوم كانت عدد
من الاشتباكات ولكن لم تكن كما عايدناها
بالامس وفي الايام الفائته وخاصه دخلنا في
الاسبوع الثاني من هذه الحرب في مدينه
بحري كان هنالك حدث بارد بنسبه كبيره يعني
كوبر ذلك المعروف بانه دائما ما يضم
قيادات ويضم يعني مجرمين كبار خاصه على
كافه المستويات وهذا السجن هو [__]
الرئيس المخلوع عمر البشير وعدد من قيادات
نظام المؤتمر الوطني المخلوع
داخل هذا يعني هنالك ايضا محكومين او
محكومون بالاعدام
وهنالك ايضا محتجزين في قضايا كثيره جدا
يجب التحقيق فيها لكن يعني حسب ما وردت من
مصادر كثيره جدا لان
الرئيس المعز
ول الاشير وعدد من القيادات السياسيه
لنظام المؤتمر الوطني انهم ما زالوا قيد
الاحتجاز ولكن هنالك فرار لعدد من السجناء
ورده معلومات بان هنالك قوه هاجمت هذا
المكان حتى الان يعني لم نتبين او لم
نستوثق من هذه القوه ولكن هذا السجن هو
يخضع
لاداره وتامين القوات المسلحه وهي يعني
دائما ما تؤمن مثلها كذا مرافق وكانت هذه
الحادثه ربما تخلق يعني
جدلا كثيف جدا
حول السجون
وقطع تامين هؤلاء المجرمين داخل
السجون خاصه ذلك فرار لسجناء من سجل الهدى
بالهمس وتجلس عمر صحيح بس عمار هناك انباء
تتحدث عن انه الحراسات قد انسحبت اصلا من
حراسه هذا السجن هل من تاكيدات
هذه المناطق تشهد حرب كرواصه
يمكن ان تنسحب وتاتي قوه مكان هذه القوه
ولكن يعني بحسب مشاهدات لان هذه المنطقه
لم تنسحب منها القوات المسلحه كانت موجوده
حتى
قبل ايام وحتى صباح اليوم ولكن ربما تنسحب
هذه القوات وتعود مره اخرى ولكن تامين
مثلها كذا منشات او سجود وفيها شخصيا
بارزه ومجرمين كبار هو سبع سؤال نصليا في
هذه النقطه هل هم داخل هذا المكان ولذلك
انسحبت هذه القوات هم خارج هذا المكان
خارج يعني تامين القوات المسلحه او حتى في
قبضه من هذه الاسئله كثيره جدا تدور الان
ولكن المصادر شعرت الى انهم ما زالوا قيد
الاحتج هذا يدل على ان القوات المسلحه ما
زالت
وتحكي الفيترضها على هذا السج على الاقل
جزء منه لانه تم اطلاق سراح او هروب عدد
من السجناء بحسب المعلومات
المتوفره هناك انباء كانت تتحدث عن انه تم
اطلاق صراحه هؤلاء لانه هناك انعدام للماء
والاكل والعلاج طوال الايام الماضيه هل من
معلومات مؤكده في هذا الاطار وهل لدينا اي
معلومات تفيد حول الوضع
لمن تبقى في هذا السجن
يعني انعدام الغذاء او الماء او العلاج
هذه يعني نقطه ربما او نقاط كثيره يعاني
منها اغلب
مواطنين الاشتباكات العسكريه ولكن هذه
المنطقه الخصوصيه يعني يعني يمكن ان يتم
تامينها
اظن ان هذا ممكنا في ظل
الوقت طالما انه هنالك
صراحه
يبدو هنالك من يتصفيه على هذا المكان ولكن
هنالك انباء
قتلها سقطوا انواع الاشتباك داخل السجن
هنالك حديث عن سته قتله من السجناء ان لم
نستفيد بعض من هذه المعلومات
تنتظر الدقائق حتى يصدر بيان ونتاكد اكثر
هذه الحادثه ربما تشير الى ان يمكن ان
تتكرر في عدد من المناطق خاصه مع انفراط
عقد الامن وهنالك حديث ايضا او مشاهد دارت
بالامس
عن اطلاق
والعصبيه بمنطقه هذا ايضا يشير على كثير
من المناطق التي بها محتجزين قد يكونوا
خارج هذه المناطق وهذا ما يؤثر على البيئه
الامنيه وما يزيد من هشاشه الوضع بشكل
مباشر من الخرطوم بحري كان معنا الصحفي
عمار ابو شيبه شكرا جزيلا لك
ازمه اخرى تشهدها السودان ازمه خبز بدات
تتفاقم حيث رصدت كاميرا العربيه احتشاد
الطوابير امام الافران دعونا متابع
لم يتوقف الامر عند ذلك حيث تهدد ازمه
المياه حياه السودانيين بعدما شهدت البلاد
انقطاع شامل للمياه الصالحه للشرب اثر
استهداف المعارك محطات المياه في العاصمه
دعونا نتابع
متى ما يجتمع عليه هؤلاء انه كنز من ماء
بئر بعد طول عناء ازمه انقطاع المياه في
السودان تدفع هؤلاء الى الامر مياه عكره
باتت بفعل الحرب صالحه للشرب فلا خيار اخر
يخاطر مدنيون في سبيل البحث عن الماء تشهد
المنطقه هنا وسط الخرطوم معارك محتدمه لم
يترك الرصاص شيئا الا وعليه اثره
يعود بعضهم محملين بما لا يروي ولا يغني
من عطش
اما على الضفه هنا نهر على سعته يلجاون
اليه يحتفظون بماء النهر حيله قد تعينهم
لايام بعد معارك سببت نقصا في المياه
الصالحه للشرب
من الصباح
انقطعت تماما المويه ونحن من سبع صباحا
بنكون في شوارع ما بنلقى قرد المويه لحدي
اذان الظهر شحوا المياه يضرب العاصمه
الخرطوم بعد معارك بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع استهدفت محطات المياه
محطات يصعب الوصول لها واصلاحها لاستمرار
الصراع في محيطها
فيما طالبت منظمه الصحه بوقف فوري لاطلاق
النار خوفا من تداعيات انسانيه قد تكون
الاسوا في تاريخ السودان غيداء السالم
العربيه
مشاهدينا التغطيه مستمره ولكن الان امر
على ابرز الاخبار الدوليه في مقابله خاصه
مع العربيه اتهم الرئيس
الاوكرنسكي اتهم الرئيس الروسي
بانه يقاتل من اجل حياته وليس من اجل
روسيا على حد تعبيره نتابع
لا استطيع بالتاكيد ان اصف الوضع بانه جيد
لكننا نكافح نحن اقوى مما كنا عليه قبل
عام لقد حررنا بعض اراضينا والبلد متحد من
اجل النصر بوتين سيفقد ما ذهب اليه بهذا
العدوان سوف يفقد ثقه شعبه في ان الدول
المجاوره لروسيا هي نفسها تماما او اسوا
سيرى الجميع كيف تتطور دول خارج النفوذ
الروسيه بوتين يقاتل من اجل حياته في
اوكرانيا انه لا يقاتل حتى من اجل روسيا
ولا من اجل لغه الروسيه
شدد ايضا للعربيه على عدم التنازل عن
مدينه باخموت مؤكدا ان التخلي عنها سيفتح
الطريق امام الروس للاستيلاء على المزيد
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
انصح جميع القاده العسكريين الاذكياء
بتحمل المسؤوليه اولا عن اقوالهم وانصح
جميع الصحفيين الذين يدعمون مثل هذه
الروايات بتحمل المسؤوليه عن افعالهم من
المستحيل التخلي عن بخموت لان هذا سيزيد
من حجم الجبهه وهذا سيعطي القوات الروسيه
وبااجنر المزيد من الفرص للاسطلاء على
المزيد من اراضينا
من جانبها قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها استطاعت السيطره على المزيد من
الاراضي في باخمت الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت
سيطرتها اعلى مربعين سكنيين غربي المدينه
كما اعلنت عن تعزيزات للشمال والجنوب عن
طريق وحدات جويه كما نفت موسكو سيطره
القوات الاوكرانيه على الضفه الشرقيه من
نهر
هذا واعلنت وزيره الداخليه الالمانيه توصل
الحكومه والنقابات العماليه الى اتفاق
بشان رواتب اكثر من مليونين ونصف المليون
موظف في القطاع العام اوضحت الوزيره في
بيان ان كل عامل سيتلقى ما مجموعه ثلاثه
الاف يورو على شكل اقساط حتى فبراير العام
المقبل للمساعده في التعويض عن التضخم
ومشاهدينا طبعا نتابع العواجل على العربيه
وزراعه خارجيه السعوديه
وبريطانيا يؤكدان على ضروره توفير الممرات
الامنه للراغبين بمغادره السودان وايضا
هناك اشتباكات الان بعد ان كان الهدوء سيد
الموقف هناك اشتباكات الان مع استمرار
عمليه اجلاء الرعايه على كل التغطيه
مستمره على راس الساعه مع ريبو كاميرا
مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات